et après la danse le théâtre la surprise
de l'amour cette pièce de marivaux est
présenté en ce moment au théâtre de
l'eldorado à paris le thème de la pièce
est éternel un homme et une femme lutte
contre leurs sentiments et finissent par
succomber à l'amour reportage de
marianne buisson et marie-pierre régal
mois les lions ont un problème avec les
femmes il a d'ailleurs décidé de ne plus
jamais tomber amoureux
oui mais voilà un jour il rencontre la
comtesse et la comtesse justement a
choisi de se passer des zones si tu ne
m'aimes pas je t'aime
le refrain n'a pas pris une seule ride
la façon dont les lieux et et je dirais
pas malheureux est blessé mais de tout
homme dans son dans son ego d'être
d'avoir été plaqué c'est absolument
extraordinaire chez d'états d'âme autour
de moi qui sont des layons quoi
d'accord le maître est un macho mais le
valais ne vaut guère mieux tous les deux
ils succombent aux pièges de l'amour
pour harlequins ce sera dans la joie et
la bonne humeur
non ça bouge c'est drôle et il ya des
choses dont les choses tendre il ya des
choses il ya donc la fameuse scène où on
est un petit peu été vers la commedia
dell arte ou là c'est franchement drôle
et puis il ya des moments très émouvants
que la fin est très émouvante beaucoup
de deux femmes des hommes je sais pas
j'en ai pas encore été demandée mais
beaucoup de femmes qui ont pleuré c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de temps de
région ce marivaudage et collector enfin
seul installé cupidon peut se retirer
la surprise de l'amour s'achève jusqu'à
la prochaine fois